[Music]
maltese
is a small island nation off the coast
of south america
over the past hundred years the country
has been ruled with an iron fist by the
herrera family
but a week ago
this guy
general silvio luna along with his
right-hand man mayor general matteo
suarez took control of the corto maltese
government in a violent military coup
the entire herrera family were hanged in
a public execution although the united
states did not condone the excesses of
the herrera regime they were
non-antagonistic toward the u.s
this is jotunheim
scientific experimentation facility
containing something known only as
project starfish
our intelligence sources tell us that
starfish is extraterrestrial in origin
in the hands of the lunar regime
it is potentially cataclysmic for
americans and the world
your mission
is to infiltrate yottenheim and destroy
every trace of project starfish how are
we supposed to get in
gaia grieves the thinker
is a geneticist in charge of project
starfish after hours he hangs out at a
gentleman's club known as la catita a
mobley
get greed's to help you by whatever
means necessary and he can get you into
yopenheim
any questions
what is that
that is an overhead projector do you
ever use it anymore no not really
so why don't you just throw it away
peacemaker
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no
no
no way collection
and yes
that is your hand and yahweh very good
we're all gonna die
i hope so
oh
[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining you suicide squad
we'll
see my court date is coming up and miss
waller said maybe you could help me out
you're flinching in my door everyone
stand down
stand down
[Music]
i won't take such extreme measures this
mission went more important than you
could possibly imagine
are you in
or out
good
let's meet your team
it's okay i'm not okay
each member has chosen for his or her
own completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf yo next time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless i mean
he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
your mission
is to destroy every trace of something
known only as project starfish any
questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no
no
all right
let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
[Music]
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the comp
[Music]